how does one become an economic hitman
well
i guess the
the first question would be why would
you want to
because i don't recommend it
for me how it happened was that
when i was
graduating just about to graduate from
business school
i was going to be drafted and i really
didn't want to go to vietnam i didn't
really want to kill vietnamese people or
be killed by them
so i was looking for a way out and i was
married at the time to a woman whose
father was very high up in the
department of the navy and his best
friend was very high up in the national
security agency which was draft
deferable
and they arranged for an interview so i
go in for this interview uh spent a
couple of days on on a lie detector and
i was sure i failed
for one thing when i had been in
middlebury college i i
uh
there was an incident with an iranian if
you can believe that be careful with
those guys
well the truth truthfully this guy
carried a knife i mean a little tiny
jackknife but he showed me how he put
his his thumb way up the blade so just a
little bit of it touching he'd already
showed me this he'd been a professional
soccer player the club of rome in in in
in in italy and then gone and then gone
to middlebury college and we i was in uh
we were in a bar together and and uh
what year is this uh
64. okay
and uh
anyways make a long story short a big
heavy farmer sucker-punched me knocked
me across the room and for hard my my
friend from iran comes up and slashes
him across the cheek lots of blood comes
out he's got this little tiny it's just
a pin perk really but it looks bad feels
bad and the farm is screaming his head
off and fahad pushes me into the men's
room and out the window into otta creek
this river that runs by and we make our
way back to the dorm at middlebury
and the next and i was pretty drunk the
next morning there's a knock on the door
and there's the cops so they pulled me
into the police station
and as i'm sitting there waiting to be
interviewed
another one's escorting for heart out he
doesn't let me talk to him they put take
me in and they start questioning me did
you see farhad with the knife and i lied
i just lied and lied and like i feared
for hard more than i feared the police
questions
i've always been told don't sit too
close to them you know i think this is
good
i'm worried about him not me yeah i get
this because i got a knife in my left
hand right now
you know so now i'm taking this this nsa
uh lie detector test and they asked me
if you ever had a have you ever been
interviewed how to run in with the
police
and i had to tell them yeah i lied to
the police so i figured well this is
this is going to screw me and then they
ask me how i feel about vietnam i say
well i i don't i don't intend to go and
so i figured i failed miserably got it
but no they hired me and you know
oh they offered me a job
and you know the truth of the matter is
they were very happy that i had the guts
to
to lie to the police
plus
fahad's father was a general in the
shah's
military
and worked for the cia
so here i was friends with a guy whose
father was in the cia and iran
that was good material and they knew
that they had already lost the war in
vietnam basically it wasn't public
knowledge really it was a lot of
controversy but the nsa knew so they
didn't care that i didn't want to go
they were pretty smart of me not to want
to go there so it was really funny so
you know i get i get to offer this job
and there's a then then i end up going
in the peace corps for three years
because they encourage that to learn
another language to learn survival
techniques et cetera et cetera and
afterwards i came out and was hired and
they told me
you know when you end up working for us
you may not actually work for us you may
work for a private corporation
but they have connections with us which
was true so i became an economist chief
economist at this consulting firm that
had very very close ties to
the united states uh
what are we going to call it
intelligence community
information gathering spy agencies did
you know at that time like are you aware
what's going on
no not really i mean
you know it's so easy to convince
yourself that you're not aware even
though i had suspicions but
i came from a poor pretty poor teachers
family in new hampshire i grew up in a
boys boarding school surrounded by rich
kids and my dad was a teacher and he
didn't make any money they the school
gave us a house and food we we had a
decent life didn't want for anything
but i was surrounded by kids that came
from tehran and paris and buenos aires
and
park avenue in new york
you know i heard all these stories and i
was stuck in this little town in new
hampshire always
and so did these kids bully you or did
you have good friendships with them i
had good friends friendships i was
pretty i was i've always been a good con
artist that's what it takes to be an
economic hitman you know
but
and i was captain of two sports teams
and so on
yeah so
but i always had this inkling to go to
tehran to go to paris to go to these
places suddenly now as i get into this
business i'm flying first class around
the world i'm meeting with presidents
i'm doing all the things that i dreamed
of doing so i really didn't want to know
the truth even though when i was the
more and more i began to suspect it but
the line that i was sold patrick was
that what you're doing is a really good
thing because what i was what i was paid
to do
was to convince countries that had
resources our corporations covet like
oil to take huge loans from the world
bank or one of the sister organizations
and hire our companies to build big
infrastructure projects like power
plants and roads and airports in these
countries which would make our
our companies would get big profits
the rich families in the country would
prosper because
they owned the industries they owned
banks they owned the things that
benefited from improved infrastructure
but the majority of the people would
suffer because money was diverted
from education
health care and other social services to
pay off the debts on the loan
and in the end they couldn't pay the
debt so we'd go back in and say hey
you owe us
so sell your oil or whatever copper
whatever the resource was
real tree cheap to our corporations
without environmental social regulations
and uh that was really
you know what my job was but
statistically you could show that when
you invest in these
um
infrastructure projects the economy
grows it does
because we measure gdp or gnp
growth
and that really just measures the very
rich so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you